building the right procedure from day
one was actually essential because
without that there will be so many other
problems now when the CTO come to me and
and it was tell me look I don't want to
have code review as a mandatory in the
early stage because it's uh it's it's
making things move slothing and I don't
want that I might have disagreed but in
that stage we find some compensating
control other okay let's say that we not
going to have a code review as a
mandatory but you must have uh what's it
so-called segregation of d is so every
time someone wants to merge a new code
change into the master Branch there's
must be another pone involved in the
process just to reduce fraud and human
[Music]
mistakes mean Galis welcome to 20 minute
leaders and the Maas experiment I'm so
excited to talk about your hypothesis
your validation and and the value that
you bring thank you so much for being
here and we're going to talk about
something that I'm really really excited
about which is uh something that I got
to experience myself in the context of
compliance and security um and um I'll
uh hopefully be able to contribute at
least with my energy that the the the
experience that I've had over the last
uh over the last few months an
experience that you're helping resolve
and turn from a a big Ketch in the
stomach to something that's actually
bearable and and maybe even enjoyable
but I'll let you tell me more about that
so mean thank thank you again for being
here thank you for having me Matas it's
pleasure to be here I have heard many
great stuff and uh you yourself very
interesting person amazing thank you but
we're gonna we're gonna focus on you now
so uh thank you for the kind words so
Miran first of all give me a bit of
background because you don't just end up
working on on making compliance fun um
how did you get here and how did you
become an entrepreneur how did you get
to compliance
um actually a funny story I was
um I didn't count from an intelligence
unit in the military yeah like many
startups in Israel does um me
establishing startup in the security
space actually I when I finished my
study I'm a b of science I stopped
working in a in a company called
ey um it's a small firm you know uh that
based all over the place and I was
getting into the technology Department
I'm doing something called talk to and
other type of security audits I was
focusing on technology R so work I
worked mainly with security uh uh uh
mainly on security compliance with uh
technology companies from the United
States and Israel and long story short
after a couple of years I ended up
managing of Engagement myself had many
many different U customers CTO VP ands
entrepreneurs founders co-founders
cisters mainly the Silicon Valley New
York Boston area and Tel Aviv uh so I
was uh on the line doing many different
Audits and I just experien to see myself
the difference between doing it for
small startups which the CTO need to run
everything like get a project without
any uh planning in advance and you know
they need to have sock to because they
need to sign some deals and that's a
deal blocker but he doesn't have too
much resources time also whe to learn
how to do sof two and compliance which
is to be honest very different from
doing compliance in large organization
like checkpoint and Google and sales
Falls and I just saw the difference I
felt there is a big pain over here I
thought there is um something that I can
contribute in simplify the process
automate the process make it it cost
less money and and here we are so uh
that was at least the beginning where I
start feeling that there's might be a
gap in the market and I might fulfill
the Gap I love it okay so so paino is
clear and I mentioned I may be able to
contribute something that paino is very
very real um I I I didn't have the the
privilege in my own journey to to use a
solution like scel or one of those in
the industry um and so I got to
experience I think at least from from a
CEO's perspective I got to experience
what my team was going through and what
that meant also on our deadlines on our
deliverables and and the complexity and
more important than the complexity May
was for us the changes that we had to do
in our workflow which all of a sudden
became it was a little bit um it was a
little bit confusing in in in many ways
understanding that okay it's not just
tactical things we need to do but it's
actually we have to change some things
in the way we work and so can can you
help me understand a little bit better
the process of getting these
compliance um processes in place what
are the main hurdles that a a startup or
a company would have to go through to
become compliant in these worlds yeah
for sure so look um early days um a
company let's say raise some money at Le
see Dr press BR even so FR um they're
looking for design Partners or they're
looking for the first customer or they
want to get their platform into uh thews
or Zoom or whatsoever
Marketplace and or they wants to raise
the next round and you know many
different incentive to go for security
compliance like sock too um but at one
stage or another they will need to get
compliant and they not if this is first
time father they not really show how the
process usually work like it might be a
little bit intimidating because uh it's
like a task for the company and the
company needs to um uh pass the test
successfully and actually this process
might be very painful uh very painful on
the one end if you don't familiar with
the process um and also the approach
that fals have in the past in till this
day they they want to move fast clearly
um minimum they want to do the minimum
at a minimum time minimum cost and and
just get the certification they've been
looking at this process actually like
checking the Box you know they didn't
really believe in the process they just
want the certification in so to it's
actually anation report so they can send
it for their cast so they might be able
to move all the side of deals but what
they don't know is that they need to
Define many different processes fors
policies stuff like that let's just take
one example uh the S softw development
life cycle um or access prage how it
work in a startup small team everyone
sit in the same room um code reviews not
mandatory uh stuff are not
documented um if you want an access you
just uh telling your next friend that's
sitting in the next T can you give me
access and that's that's just about it
the problem over there is that it's not
scalable it's not secure and it's not
compliant so this is where companies and
startups M need to adjust their
processes and procedure from very early
stage in order to build the foundation
for a company for for a a healthy scale
up
when it come for uh for their security
and compliance in order for customer to
trust on their organization and not
creating any risk for their customers
you know it's this is like in haare so
companies can have in order to reduce
their risk in some cases just the first
stage that they need to do in order to
uh um to start an engagement start
working with one of their potential
customers absolutely I mean listen I
mean there's there's so many situations
that I hear about out and experienced
myself that you go and you build and you
say okay there's this amazing solution
that I want to build as a company I I
even raise funds and I bring the amazing
researchers we build amazing technology
and I come and I sit with in in my case
it was a few banks in Canada and the US
and we're sitting and we have an amazing
meeting amazing second meeting third
meeting we want to do a PC together and
and and now let's and and then they okay
great and and here just the security
compliances we want to make sure that
you have and I'm looking at that and I'm
saying oh wow okay so I I guess we're
not ready and uh and you know we we had
it I guess easy year because we caught
on to that just maybe nine or 10 months
into development um and it's an
interesting question by the way and I
would love to see pick your brain I
asked my our Engineers whether we should
have started that process earlier let's
say on day
Zero they said they're not sure and it
was because I was asking them you know
we just spent about 3 weeks weeks heads
down doing this should we have just
started the beginning and they they gave
me an interesting tradeoff when it comes
to the speed of development which got us
to this point I'd love to hear your take
on when is sort of the right time to do
this um look first I would love to
usually it's every case is a stand alone
but when I speak with Prospect I I my
first question is that why do you need
so to in the first place like I know
it's good I know it's can reduce a risk
but why do you need it like that's is
something that you need to put up your
resources on um it's might hold you a
little bit back why do you need to have
it and um this is how I usually start
because I know there is a trade-off and
you need to balance between um building
a strong Foundation of compliance for
the one end to um still moving fast with
the business and development and how I
look at things is that I believe as long
as you start earlier it's going to be
easier down the road um now I know
developers and Founders want to move
fast um and having your CTO uh spending
his time on sock 2 rather than building
the architecture recruiting Talent you
know uh uh developing
some new features or fixing some bugs
you know it's might still secondary but
the time that you're going to get some
kind of a humano which a custom
might get a disclose information which
they shouldn't allow to or you might
have any security incident that's the
point that we're gonna miss you know so
heartbeat and you're gonna say Oh Why
didn't it start earlier and balancing
between the R&D requirement and moving
fast on the one end to compliance does
it necessarily needs to be that
complicated can give you an example that
they work with the company um they grew
very fast in like for 50 emplo es to
almost 4,000 employees in three years
they acquired many companies and there
was massive massive uh uh um scale up
and growth and for them building the
right procedure from day one was
actually essential because without that
there will be so many other problems now
when the CTO come to me and and was tell
me look I don't want to have code review
as a mandatory in the early stage
because it's uh it's it's making things
move slothing and I don't want that I
might have disag read but in that stage
we find some compensating control them
okay let's say that we not going to have
a code review as a mandatory but you
must have uh what's So-Cal segregation
of Duties so every time someone want to
merge a new code change into the master
Branch there's must be another person
involved in the process just to reduce
fraud and human mistakes so building
this up from day one actually now when
they have like not a a team of the of
eight people in the development team but
uh I think almost I don't know like 200
or maybe even more F built up good from
day one and and you know it's it's
continuous improvements it's never stops
you all the time wants to to improve you
want to optimize you want to move faster
and you wants to be more secure
absolutely so walk me through site
tailes Journey so you going back to to
you identifying the pain point and
saying okay I think I can I can create
value here um you you obviously are um
and you you've been at this for a while
now so to walk me through a little bit
of the story of of SEL up until today
all right look in the beginning I didn't
even think about stopping SEL I was
writing a Blog about Saku because there
was almost no information at all about
Saku and I just found this very like
interesting and that there is no
information so I was writing my blog
it's called sock to .io was the first
blog maybe in the world about talk to
and you know I start thinking about how
I can improve the process on a product
perspective and then uh I've been
introduced to an investor from the re
Tech space based in the UK and they have
a large group of of compliance companies
many financi space and um it sounds
interesting the idea of security
compliance and not Financial compliance
it's still very good with the portfolio
so uh uh we start discussing about that
and and that's how I actually started
you know uh that's how I raise money and
I I stop building the company but I had
in mind not a solution that's limited
only for the technology which is crucial
and it's majority of our solution but
giv closing the loop for companies for
startup for snbs when it come for they
need a platform of course to automate
use a single source of proof to simplify
the process to collaborate and so on and
so on and so on but they also need
someone to manage the platform so in
many case that's going to be the CTO but
then you're just giv another
responsibility for the C and you already
have so many others responsibility like
build a platform you know build features
um so what they want to do is to give a
hybrid solution from the one end given
the eois platform so they can do it by
themselves but if they want an
integrated solution with also someone
that can take the
from from engineering team we also
Supply an expert that can uh prepare the
company from early days do 90% of the
work from them navigate for the process
VI a pmo also uh uh manage the audit for
them and just make sure that they are
compliance and then we start getting
more requests for penetration testing
and audit so we created a a an integrate
solution that close the load for for
startups when they need everything like
they need to have pentest they need an
audit they want someone to help them and
consult them and they need an automation
so we that's that's our service software
we actually providing everything on this
single roof and uh in order for to
enable companies to move fast to cut
approximately 50% of the total cost of
compliance and make the time to
compliance three times faster because
most of my customer when I asked them
when do you need the sock too they told
me yesterday you know how it
is I I have absolutely know and know how
it is H I love it and I and I love how
you are describing the Journey of of
what you're doing first is it sounds
like it it's starting off well your your
your experience with thei and and
security compliance I mean you you've
lived through the processes you've seen
it firsthand you're going You're about
to to bring value to the world through
something as simple but but meaningful
as a blog post where you're where you're
bringing your own thoughts and your own
ideas and realizing what what way I can
actually do this now and and not just um
establish the pain point but I can go
and solve it and then you're describing
how the growth of the company is very
much structured by the demand that
you're seeing firsthand and it also
sounds with the notion of putting in the
pmos but having those expert opinions
you're you're effectively creating a a
fe an immediate feedback loop for your
own company on what works what doesn't
work how do we continue optimizing the
process whereas you mentioned it at a a
you know a sentence at the end there
which was you know and that person is
there to make sure that the company's
compliant right so so your the value
that you're eventually providing the
customer is is really the core
fundamental value here um and and
everything all the bells and whistles
you're doing are to help just optimize
to get that faster and and obviously the
expansion to different elements so I
know I just caught a bit of the a bit of
the journey but Mir I want to share you
know extended thanks for sharing with me
your your experiment your hypoth is and
uh and I really appreciate your time and
your energy I think it's super super
cool space having lived through the
paino myself and and I want to wish you
best of luck with SEL and uh we'll
continue touring from the
side Cole thank you so much M was
pleasure meeting you thanks for having
me thank you Mayan thank you thank you